[Music]
[Music]
alimony in Kenya the wildlife
conservation areas they are quiet
[Music]
this all changes when the phone rings
the because ie the team can be contacted
at all times
we are the first mobile security patrol
virtual team in this part of Kenya
typically an animal is trapped in
approach is near but it can be anything
a lion which needs to be translocated or
a sexy bra but usually suspension our
kids include gloves first-aid kit
medical supplies blindfold
drop and carry life the team consists of
a driver uh Nesbitt and two ranges once
we have assembled everything we are
ready to go unsafe the enemy
the roles are not usually failed most of
the time we play through the bush we are
going to see
enriched and more we have to keep them
than most have another self because
become debilitated because of the snails
multitude we only have a few minutes
ones and must been tranquilized and it
can be very dramatic
complete back in the compound we are
bigger team just have one more keeper
take care of the orphans our lab
technician takes care of the blood walk
a Kohana manages our online presence
this job is important because as is a
lot of contribute to human beings and
wildlife
therefore in division who say fire life
from becoming extinct is very crucial
allow so much to save lives and see
animals our and that is our calling
that's why I do
[Music]
you